[Music]
hello Internet I'm Dave ruin this is the
Ruben report it's November 16th 2023 we
are live streaming on Rumble YouTube and
locals share subscribe tap the
notification Bell we are doing a Ruben
report locals Community Q&A today after
I get to the to the big story of the day
which is oddly uh I would say depressing
and personal for me uh but lighting fire
across the internet and I sort of had to
address it even though I discussed with
Phoenix this morning is there anything
else we can do apparently we can't we
have to talk about this Ben Candace
thing so we are going to get to that uh
we will do some uh questions after and
as always we are uh live at 1M today on
people of the internet and uh we'll just
see what happens with this whole
internet that does seem to be uh fraying
and going off in some crazy uh
directions at the moment okay so let me
just address something up top before I
get into the Ben Candace thing and I'm
sure some of you those of you who are
not on Twitter and God bless you for not
on Twitter and don't get on Twitter and
I envy you to be quite honest um you may
not have seen it but but Ben Shapiro and
Candace Owens got into a big Twitter
spot last night and then subsequently
like within hours Candace was on Tucker
on X on Twitter uh but they had
obviously taped that before the thing so
some of it seemed somewhat premeditated
or whatever uh but the reason this one
is going to be a bit difficult for me is
I consider myself friends or at least
was friends with the parties involved uh
and you know as I mentioned yesterday
when we did that thing about Nikki Haley
uh you know where she wanted to make
sure that people on the internet
couldn't be anonymous when I talk about
some of these people I've come to know a
lot of these people in some some in
different capacities but like Nikki's
literally been to my house for dinner so
it's not the most thing to CR fun thing
for me to criticize her but obviously it
is my job to call balls and Strikes as I
see them but that can be kind of
difficult you know what was it three or
four days ago I I covered how Jen yuger
the host of The Young Turks he was my
boss and we were for some period of time
during that used to play basketball
every Sunday he's gone off the complete
deep end and and I would say is
basically a Hamas supporting lunatic and
going after me constantly and finally I
I did one video about him like these
things happen I know the presidential
candidates I know these people it's
weird it's it's weird so I just am
prefacing all of this by saying that I
will try to do this as honestly as
possible and I will also try to mend
some of this stuff because I know
everybody on the internet wants
everything to be who owns who and who
destroys who and now it is fueled to
Nikki's point yesterday it is fueled by
Bots it is fueled by Ai and the worst
behaviors go the most viral and the
people who are decent get left behind
and that is largely part of our problem
it's partly why we why things keep
getting worse because the all the
incentive structures on social media and
the way we behave with each other
incentivize the worst behaviors so
anyway all of that to be said I going to
try to do this right so bear with me as
we do it so look I I have been friends
with both Ben and Candace for for quite
some time I actually uh was really the
first person to put Candice on the map
and you can judge me accordingly uh but
Candice was a little YouTuber at first
her name was red pill black and the day
that I sat down with her this is back in
2017 this feels like many many lifetimes
ago to me we sat down in my garage and
we were doing something called YouTube
week at the time where we were just
trying to grab YouTubers across all
different verticals you didn't have to
be political but just talk to people
about whatever they were doing on
YouTube and somebody brought this girl
red pill black to me I I literally did
not know Candace's name until a minute
before we sat down I knew her as this
red pull black person anyway we sat down
I want to start today with a little
portion of that first interview that I
did with Candace back in 2017
joining me today is a YouTuber who has
done pretty much the scariest thing that
one person can do she has come out
as conservative the scariest of all
words Candace Owens AKA Red Pill black
welcome to the Ruben report thank you
I'm so happy to be here right now who is
this Candice person all right let's just
do some history for the people that
don't know about you at all um I am
honestly I'm just I'm just a girl that
makes videos uh the history As I Grew
grew up in Stanford Connecticut I went
to school at the University of Rhode
Island um pursued a degree in journalism
which is quite ironic whoa someone that
studied journalism that's trying to tell
the truth this is fascinating absolutely
um after college I was in a lot of
student loan debt you know I came from a
family that doesn't have any money
whatsoever and I had to just pay it back
so the smartest move for me was to go
into Finance I hit the ground running in
New York City worked at a private Equity
Firm for 4 years uh left that firm and
wanted to do my own anti-bullying
startup thing that went really sideways
when the left tried to do hit pieces on
me during the election and that was my
red pill moment okay so that was just
like a little bite I just wanted you to
see like our first those were literally
our first moments ever together again
back in 2017 we shot that at about I
think 1: p.m. in the afternoon Candace
who was there with a friend of hers uh
they ended up staying over for dinner
many many bottles of wine and David's
famous chicken parm later she left at
probably about midnight and and we've
become very good friends uh subsequently
over the years here here's just a couple
pictures of Candace and I together over
the years the first ones at a Christmas
party that one's the second one's on her
set at the daily wire the third one
there obviously is at her wedding we did
not get married ourselves but that's at
her wedding and the other one is from a
different appearance when she was on the
Ruben report so before I dive into the
the fraus between uh her and Ben I want
to now jump to my first interview with
Ben Shapiro which was in 2016 so it was
just a few months before that and what
you'll find more interesting about this
one perhaps uh is that this is when I
was just breaking from the left like it
was just happening and I was like oh
something's crazy with the left let me
talk to these scary people on the right
and a lot of people said talk to this
scary guy Ben Shapiro all right well I'm
I'm very happy that you're here because
I have had all of Twitter basically
saying to me for about six months you've
got to talk to this guy this is the guy
who will either convert you to
conservatism or you guys are just going
to hate each other I'll turn you into a
flaming Bernie Sanders socialist yeah
that's that's pretty much pretty sure
you're that's not the direction good so
it'll be a conservative by the end of
the conversation so well let's see let's
you would agree that racism exists right
that there are people that are
legitimate racist it would be idiotic to
to think otherwise of course there are
legitimate racists and we should Target
them and we should find them and we
should hurt their careers because racism
is unacceptable but what I don't agree
with is this I don't like fighting
Phantoms as I said earlier institutional
racism is a meaningless phrase libraries
are not racist schools not racist you
have to show me a law a policy a person
who's racist you can't just say American
society is racist because that doesn't
mean anything okay the same bench app
that you know now I do have to say I'm
aging quite well if that's my main
takeaway of today's program um here's a
couple other pictures of Ben and I over
the years again I'm just trying to
illustrate oh here's just one this was
the big famous IDW dinner night that's
me and Ben and Eric Weinstein and and
Jordan and Rogan and and Sam Harris
anyway I'm showing you all of this just
to say these people have been in my
world uh friendships in in different
ways I was just with Ben in London at
the Jordan show and all of that stuff um
so there's a long history there okay uh
I am going to try to do this right as I
said but this is personal and I also
know that there's a weird thing with the
internet which is that no matter how
calmly I try to lay any of this out to
you there are a certain set of people
that will just try to drag me in on it
and you know that there are I like it's
these are inner internet things but
there are literally telegram groups
where they post people's tweets and then
they send the Bots to you and all that
like there is a very evil game being
played right now it also has to do with
the Tik Tok algorithm and everything
else but I will try to address this
properly so should we get to the first
uh for the first tweet here um and as
you know uh well all right let's get to
the first tweet so Candace tweeted this
out yesterday blessed are the
peacemakers for they shall be called the
children of God blessed are they which
are persecuted Ed for righteous for
righteousness sake for theirs is the
Kingdom of Heaven blessed are ye when
men shall revile you and persecute you
and shall say all manner of evil against
you falsely for my sake no one can serve
two masters e either you will hate the
one and love the other or you will be
devoted to the one and despise the other
you cannot serve both God and money so
obviously she is quoting the Bible there
uh but many people immediately picked up
on uh especially because of the last
line there that she was going after Ben
because in the course of the last uh 6
weeks since October 7th uh she's been
bizarrely silent uh I think most
objective people would say she's been
sort of bizarrely Silent about the Hamas
atrocities and sort of said well I'm not
an expert in this area of the world
although personally I don't think you
have to be an expert to realize that you
know chopping women's heads off and and
baking babies alive and all of the other
stuff is you don't have to be an expert
in anything to understand that that's
that's bad but then there's been this
sort of like ongoing feud between the
two of them and by the way there's been
an ongoing feud even way before this
because obviously when Kanye West was
having his complete meltdown and saying
all these horrific things about the Jews
and all that Candice was obviously
associated with that and everything else
so clearly people felt she was going
after Ben like Ben you either for God or
for money now Ben at the at the daily
water does pay her salary but clearly
people knew it was it was a hit on Ben
so Ben retweeted it and wrote this
Candace if you feel that taking money
from the daily wire somehow comes
between you and God by all means quit
now before I uh read Candace's response
to that I think largely What's Happening
Here some of this stuff is kind of
genuine and everyone's emotions are are
a little frayed over the last six weeks
or whatever but I think largely What's
Happening Here is and I don't know any
insid or information on this this is
just my suspicion Candace's contractor
has got to be coming to an end I suppose
in six months or a year or something
like that and obviously Ben has sort of
had it with her and as you know after
the Kanye stuff and everything else and
she kind of wants to get fired right
because the best thing for her would be
to be fired because then she can use
that his fuel to go do something else
whether it's Solo or it's with Tucker or
whatever it whatever else it might be it
doesn't seem like Ben wants to fall for
that so he's basically being like look
if you have a problem with me and you're
making this about money and God and
everything else you can quit anyway
Candice then responded to that and said
you have been acting unprofessional and
emotionally unhinged for weeks now and
we have all had to sit back and allow it
and have all tried to exercise exceeding
understanding for your raw emotion but
you cross a certain line when you come
for scripture and read yourself into it
I will not tolerate it um I I don't know
exactly what that means he wasn't
mocking the Scripture it was fairly
obvious she was going after him um also
I don't know what she means about him
being like overly emotional or whatever
yes a lot of people have been very
emotional for this past six weeks and by
the way it's not just Jews the the sheer
barbarity of the things that we have
seen uh generally if I think you were a
thinking emotional functioning person
you would be pretty um upset by what
happened uh but I think it also would be
fair to say that if you were Jewish per
se although Christians kind of care
about Israel too and that's where Jesus
was from and all that kind of thing uh
you might there there was something so
horrific about this that you might be a
little more emotional but I just don't
really understand what she's saying
there uh she Then followed up one more
time and wrote uh you are utterly out of
line for suggesting that I cannot quote
Biblical scripture the Bible is not
about you um again he didn't say that
she can't quote Biblical scripture um
the Bible is not about you seems like a
particularly sort of Nefarious little
line that she was given there but okay
again I'm trying not to attack hack
anyone specifically I'm just kind of
reading it out and give you a little bit
of my thoughts on that now what was
interesting about the timing of all of
this is that Tu Candace had already
taped an interview with Tucker Carlson
that was airing last night so she knew
that she had already discussed some
stuff about Ben on Tucker because they
don't air Tucker live like I'm doing
this live they had taped it and they
were about to air it and then that
fracus happened on Twitter which then
led to you know like two hours later
here is a portion of Candice on Tucker
Carlson of Ben Shapiro who you work with
at the daily wire I think it's for say
attacking you here's the video I just
want to get your reaction to it the
question is about Candace ens I think
her behavior during this has been
disgraceful
without yeah she work my company I think
she's been absolutely disgraceful I
think that her her sophistication on
these particular issues has been
ridiculous everybody can see the moves
that she's making and the things that
she's saying and iable what is that
about there there's nothing that He has
expressed in that at least in that short
clip that he fundamentally disagrees
with in terms of what I said but I will
say I'm not going to respond with the
same Ed hobin and attex I don't think it
helps further discussion and it if that
was me that was caught on a video saying
that about colleagues that I work with I
would be embarrassed I would so I think
that the video speaks more to Ben's
character than it speaks to mine has he
texted you to apologize or explain or
anything no nothing I haven't heard a
single word it just was sort of
something that he said and you know what
Ben and I have many disagreements so I
don't think that that's particularly
something that's interesting um we
disagreed on the covid vaccine we
disagree on Ukraine and Russia he has
taken virtually every stance that has
been the opposite of mine on every issue
uh over the last five years okay so I
first just want to reiterate something
about the timing this was all sort of
planned so that the Tucker thing was
going to air with maximum sort of chaos
around it right maximum verality around
it which is why she sent out that tweet
and then Ben in his own way you could
criticize Ben and say Ben you fell for
it right you should have just Let It Be
she she quoted the Bible clearly she was
going after you it's obvious she knows
what she's doing let's not pretend
anything otherwise um but but Ben did I
suppose fall for it in that sense and
then again there are these telegram
channels that then they post tweets and
then they send all of the most the worst
possible things that you could read
about somebody they they go after Ben
probably more than anybody else they're
not thrilled with me either um but part
of this is also that this this is sort
of one of the things that Candice likes
to do and I don't even again Candice if
you're watching this or if your people
are going to send this to you later I'm
actually not going after you personally
here this is we've gotten into it a
little bit on Twitter actually even even
two weeks ago or so related to uh some
of the Hamas stuff um but she does like
to fight with people on Twitter she's
done it with Megan Kelly and with
Stephen Crowder and probably even Trump
at DES santis and Jeremy and who and Ben
and whoever like and with rap stars and
Kim Kardashian I don't know exactly but
like it's part of like what the thing is
right um
so Ben said that she has faux
sophistication when talking about these
issues I mean I think that that is
personally I think that that is a fair
issue we showed you the clip uh what was
it last Friday where she was talking
about the Muslim quarter in Jerusalem as
if Israel keeps Muslims in a specific
quarter Israel is the one that has
opened up Jerusalem to everyone the
quarters the Jewish quarter the Muslim
quarter The Armenian quter have existed
for thousands and thousands of years had
Israel gone in and be like been like
this quarter can't be Muslim anymore we
have to integrate it people would have
said the Israelis are racist Chinese
people live in Chinatown um so she has
had a level of FO sophistication uh but
it's also she says that he's not
criticizing what I say but I think a lot
of the criticizm criticism that's been
leveled at her has been it's what she
won't say like just flat out say that
Hamas is bad and and all of the obvious
stuff I think that that's what some of
the criticism is and I have no no doubt
this I'm just Paving the way for me to
get involved in this which is not really
what my intention was but it's just how
it is
um okay so now I want to jump back for a
second to uh to another clip on Tucker
last night because this I think maybe
gets to the heart in a less personal way
about what's going on here largely in
terms of our national conversation so
here they are talking about the how the
emotions over the last month um in
Tucker's estimation have been
disregulated
there's also I can't help but notice
that I your views reflect mine I would
say pretty much I'm an American I was
horrified by what happened on October
7th I think was pretty strange um I
don't really understand how it happened
but Innocents died and that's awful and
I hated watching that and I feel so
sorry for the Israelis um who were
killed however there's an emotional
response that is disproportionate I
think on the part of some commentators I
mean our country is being invaded right
now Now by millions of young men whose
identities we don't know who probably
don't even like America and they're now
living here over 100,000 Americans di
year of fentanyl I've known a couple
those are real tragedies I've never seen
anything like the emotion from any
commentator around those tragedies as
I'm watching about a foreign tragedy I
think that's odd okay first off I have
to address one thing up top which is
that this is not purely a foreign
tragedy uh we think that probably 20
Americans were killed and that there are
probably 12 Americans that are still
hostages right now I don't I don't see
any emotion from them about that that
that M look I will grant the the longest
leash possible maybe that was a total
oversight on Tucker's part right there
maybe I don't know but I want to hit a
couple points here uh you know a few
things can be true at once Tucker is not
wrong that as Americans we should always
prioritize America's interests first
before any Nation when he talks about
conservative commentators I don't think
he's talking about me specifically but
do I talk about this the Border
virtually every day on this show and
connect that to the drug problem and
what it's doing to our inner cities and
everything else I have no doubt that Ben
Shapiro is doing that as well and Glenn
Beck is doing that as well and
everything else so uh he's so that's
just one little piece here but Americans
ought to be able to be a pro-america
first and and understand that there are
people who slightly emote differently
and prioritize differently and all of
those things and by the way we have
candid who address these things a little
bit differently right we have Trump who
addresses it in one way and Des santis
who addresses it in one way and Nikki
Haley who addresses it in one way but
the point is that we should be able to
walk and chew gum at the same time right
and of course you should be able to be
concerned about our border and want our
border I how many times on this show
have I said that we should be closing
down our border and we should not be
letting any of these people in and we
have to figure out who's here and we're
going to have to get rid of some of them
and all of those things and we all know
I know people who have died of fentol I
know someone who's who's hooked on
fentanyl right now um so everyone is
concerned about these things it is
possible that the sheer barbarity of the
events and and the videos that we've
shown you here and some of the ones that
you've seen elsewhere or that I don't
even want to show you uh would would jar
some people into being more emotional it
is also possible that Jews in general
might be generally speaking a little
more thin skinned when there's a massive
attack against them because Jews have
been programmed and Holocaust and
everything else across the globe so Jews
might be a little more sensitive to that
uh but it is also true that we should
all care about not only the American
citizens over there but that there is a
civilizational battle happening right
now right what have I been saying for
weeks now if if you think that when
they're done with the Jews over there
they're going to magically be done with
the Jews in London but it's not the Jews
that's the point that they're going to
magically be done with all the Western
values in London and Paris and belg
Belgium and Montreal and everywhere else
well of course they're not going to be
it is just going to be the beginning so
when when they're going for the Jews now
it is the whites next and I think I have
offered a pretty fair defense of white
people on this show a well-deserved uh
uh defense because of course the Jews
are just the first line in what actually
is going on here so then it hearkens to
the to the question does this mean that
America should get involved militarily
and and send our troops across the
Middle East and everything else no I'm
not for that I'm actually not for that
what I am for is that we can offer a lot
of diplomatic support we can offer a
certain amount of weapons as needed to
understand to beat an evil terrorist
organization the same way we defeated
Isis and nobody said that we shouldn't
be allowed to we might want to do
something like that um but okay all of
that said uh I did respond to that clip
on Twitter uh and a lot of people
thought I kind of nailed that I just
sort of summed it up right now but I
said there are at least 12 American
hostages note they don't get emotional
about them at all like like if this is
about Americans shouldn't Tucker and
Candice be really emotional about those
uh Americans that are likely under the
shifa host hospital right now also
virtually every conservative leaning
commentator has been talking about the
border and drug trafficking maybe
something uniquely horrific about what
Hamas did is causing emotion so there is
a weird element there related to oh it's
you know like some people say Israel has
a disproportionate response and
basically what Tucker and and Candace
are saying is oh they're having a
disproportional emotional response to
1500 people dead which again would be
like 10 911s or whatever it is 15 911s
you know when you mark it up for uh
relative population um I also have no
problem saying something that I've
consistently said on the show which is
we should build a wall we should have
that border as I already referenced we
should figure out how to stop the fenel
crisis from happening I happen to think
Rhonda santis would be the best guy to
do that but Donald Trump would certainly
be better than Biden and then we also do
have to figure out because this would be
the most American thing that we could do
we are going to have to figure out who
is in this country illegally first but
then also legally who are bloodthirsty
terrorist sympathizers and
co-coordinators and all of that who are
would be happy to have buses blow up
that would kill Jews and white people
and black people and Asians and so forth
right because all of those groups and
every other group that I didn't mention
there Native American and
indian-american and everything else are
Americans are Americans and that is what
they are coming after so just because
you're concerned more about the Border
doesn't make you an anti-semite
obviously but just because you're
concerned about the barbarity that just
happen that just happened in Israel
doesn't make you like some sort of
America last BLM activist and we better
start real realizing that because
watching the right fry right now and
maybe that was maybe they maybe they're
just all playing us like a fiddle um but
none of these things are mutually
exclusive and and that's what it means
to be an American so that Walkin chew
gum thing like we can do a bunch of
stuff at once we don't have to blow
apart the world to occasionally do
things that are right across the across
the pond right we are America is the
dream of the world and has been the most
extraordinary nation in the world
because we are a Melting Pot who all
share one thing in common we are all
Americans right we all had our foods and
our traditions and our musics and our
music and our cultures and our clothing
and we all came here and we built
something born out of the
judeo-christian tradition and by the way
it is a judeo Christian tradition right
Christianity was born out of Judaism
these two things are distinct and
different but this country has room for
both of those peoples and it has room
even for peop that do not believe in
that but they have to believe in the
institutions that we create and we have
been under a decade long many decade
long but hyper uh hyper attack in the
last decade of all of our institutions
our media has failed us our education
has failed us and now and now the
algorithms are making us crazy the Bots
are making everybody
crazy and we have some work to do
because the the last thing that we
should be doing right now is that I
suspect as although obviously I fall
let's say a little more in the bend camp
on on this Feud with Candace that Ben
Shapiro and Candace Owens probably
mostly want to live in the same country
together probably and I guess I can't
speak for both of them right now but at
least or let's put it this way how about
the people that largely support Candace
and the people that largely support Ben
generally tend to be right-leaning
people they tend to be partly you guys
watching this right you just might like
the way Ben speaks a little faster than
me or you might like that you might
listen like listening to Candace for
whatever reason or me for whatever
reason but all of us that are roughly on
this side of thing that we understand
how evil the woke left is that we
understand that collectivism is the
enemy and all of that this thing that's
happening right
now is not good and we better figure out
how to uh uphold our Traditions before
we shred them all right in front of our
eyes because that's exactly what they
want us to do so now I have one more
thing before you before we get to the uh
the community Q&A because the Rock yes
the rock of all people I get most of my
deep philosophical and religious uh and
patriotic Notions from The Rock uh he
was on Joe Rogan and he talked a bit
about this was in the context of talking
about the the horrific fire in Maui from
a couple months ago but talked about
what brings America together in the
middle of the ocean that's created
Islands yeah and that's America 50th
state yeah it's wild but if we are if
that is America we should treat it like
it's America and we should protect it
like it's America and we should help
them like it's America Protect it to the
core and 700 bucks per person is not
doing that at all a onetime payment it's
so insulting and so insane in the light
of all this public knowledge of the
amount of money that we're sending to
other countries yeah well you know what
we did on this fund just so you know
it's $1,200 per month oh that's great
it's great for months and uh any anyone
who's verified and you know with
Polynesian culture um there's it's U
there's a lot of people in the house at
times like and and uncles and
grandparents so there's some houses that
are getting four five $6,000 that's
great that's really great yeah yeah
that's something and again it should be
coming from the government and it could
be done it's not something that couldn't
be done I mean it's something that
everybody would support take care of our
own take care of our own first yeah I
mean what otherwise what are we if we're
not a country if we're not a it's the
same thing with family right like you
would take care of your family first I
take care of my family first take care
of our American people it's a community
we should be a community yeah and we're
so divided and polarized right now and I
think a lot of that is accentuated by
social media it's funny Rogan saying
take care of us first like that's Donald
Trump stuff Rogan did not vote for
Donald Trump either time as far as I
know I don't think he voted either time
if I'm not mistaken but I'm happy to be
corrected on that but the point the
overriding point is yes what's happening
right now is we have we have so many
people that can now blatantly see that
our government is not taking care of us
first that we are now fighting with each
other over whatever the scraps are and
that is not good and that doesn't mean
we can't do good in the world you know
it doesn't mean you have to Nation build
everywhere I think that large experiment
is over and most of the people who were
for nation building uh are in the dust
bin of history at this point but if we
are not the world's leader guess what
China gladly will be and China might
just take over California because
they're they've got XI jingping in San
Francisco literally today and they
cleaned up the cities for him so we
might just start selling our cities and
our states to China do you think the
world would be better off if China had a
bigger role and the United States had a
lesser role again that doesn't mean we
have to bomb every country but the but
if we could get back to what our
national ethos is and what the purpose
of America was and if we could spread
those ideas not by gun but by by through
culture and through goodness and through
teaching people what Freedom really
means that would be good for basically
everybody uh so well I can already see
we have a couple questions about the
Candace thing uh in the community so
let's just dive right into it so Matthew
says do you believe Candace owens's
career on The Daily wire is on thin ice
well of course it's on thin ice and and
it's been on thin ice probably I I I'm
not speaking for anyone at the daily wi
I want to be clear about that um it's
obviously Been On th I to some degree
for a while right like she helped usher
in this Kanye thing Kanye can we at
least all say that Kanye is a bit of a
Jew haer right I'm not sitting here
telling you Candace is a Jew hater but
can we at least all say that Kanye is um
and she has offered a huge defense of
him over over time right and by the way
when Kanye first came out and was waking
up and you know his original tweet was
uh I like the way Candace Owens thinks
and that was while Candace was big in
Trump World like I was excited about
that it felt like wow there was going to
be this ushering an Awakening within the
black community I hate those phrases but
that black people were suddenly going to
be like oh I we don't have to vote 90%
Democrat and by the way when you as a
group vote 90% one way that the people
you're voting for cut suddenly realize
oh you don't have to do anything for
these people because they keep voting
for us no matter what um but again I
think what's happening right now is she
knows that they're the daily wire
obviously is not going to renew her
contract right they're not you know she
had a talk show that I did many times in
front of a live Studio H it was very
expensive that show folded so they there
may be financial reasons maybe there
wasn't enough viewership I I I'm not
privy to the in inside analytics on all
of that but the point is there's enough
tension there at this point and I've
seen a whole bunch of people that have
cancelled D wire cuz they're not happy
that they haven't got rid of her that I
that it's it's just fairly obvious like
I know enough about contracts and I know
and I've negotiated with all of these
companies from daily wire to blaze and
Rumble at all these guys and fox and
blah blah like she wants to get fired
because the the chaos of being fired
would be like Oh see it would basically
be like see Ben the Jew and daily wire
they fired me now I'm going to go build
my own thing like it would it would add
Rocket Fuel to whatever she wants to do
next and by the way she has every right
to do whatever she wants to do next
Quinn says questioned renewing my daily
wire Plus subscription due to the feud
but after watching Candace's interview
with Tucker decided to go ahead and
renew I watch more of other shows on
there anyway and my son likes the new
bent key shows the Maga or America First
vers GOP establishment seems to be a
wider Gap than 2015 it tends to show at
the House of Representatives voting on
bills how do they try to come together
during the general election well first
off everyone should spend their dollars
as they see fit so you may not like
handis but as you said if your kid likes
the Ben key stuff so Ben key is their
knew um it's their kids programming on
daily wire then it's like you have to
make that choice right like there are
people who choose uh to support us on
locals and some people want to watch and
don't support some people don't have the
means like everyone and everyone in
their own way like or not everyone but
most people have like a certain budget
let's say for entertainment every month
and you could be like all right well I
do want to spend the 14 bucks I you know
I've got 30 bucks well 14 of it's going
to Netflix and five bucks is going to
Reuben and then I've got you know 12
bucks left and you know maybe that's
going to the Daily wire or it's going to
this or I just want to buy a freaking
beer you know whatever it might be so
you should vote with your dollars right
I I I absolutely firmly believe that and
those of you who support me here allow
me to just do what I think is right and
not be associated with anybody so there
you go um oh but sorry but your question
really was that the the the fraying of
the movement so there now seems to be
this let's say it's like a Tucker
Candice road that we can go down here
and there seems to be more of I don't
know I don't even I want to make it
about Tucker and Candace in b and anyway
you you can all see what the fissure is
starting to look like honestly I think
there's a way out I think Des santis is
the guy that's way out by the way
Candace took a couple really cheap shots
at DES santis in the interview implying
that he was a neocon and all the people
supporting him are never trumpers and
it's like it's the craziest thing I've
ever heard everyone I meet everywhere I
go are two times Trump supporters or at
least one time Trump supporters they all
say the same thing we've just had it
with the drama and we think Dan santis
is a better younger version of all of
this and he's done such a great job in
Florida we can move that forward um but
I think I think a Florida model without
drubbing the the horse the dead horse on
this is the model out that where you're
still doing all as D santis often says
no one has been more America First than
him and and accomplished more of the
goals of that movement uh and when you
say if if you're concerned about the
border and you want some people deported
and all those things it's like who's
going to do it who has the best track
record of doing what they say I think
the answer is obvious Elizabeth says is
there a way for us to push push past the
propaga Anda and convince people of what
is really true I do not know Elizabeth I
do not know I I am trying to do it
desperately but it is getting
increasingly difficult and I'm telling
you there are so many levels to how
screwy this whole thing is right now I
don't I'm not trying to blackpill you
guys you know I'm I try to do this and
always veering towards we can get out of
this and by the way we can get out of
this and we will get out of this that is
the story of humanity that is literally
the story of the Bible if we can go
biblical um humans will always go
through through horrible times and evil
will always be there and there are ways
out that that is the point of of the the
story of being a human uh but we have we
have very special conditions right now
the algorithms and the fact that we know
specifically Tik Tok but but it's the
other ones to are pushing mass
disinformation and I don't think you the
answer necessarily is Banning Tik Tok
and I certainly don't think the answer
is that nobody can be anonymous online
but we have a Confluence of things
happen so we have a Chinese app that is
pushing all sorts of divisive
information to our children then we have
we have Educators who don't educate so
kids are kids brains are being blown
apart and if you thought that confusing
kids about their gender would just stay
in the realm of gender well once you get
a kid to be like oh my parts don't match
what my brain says then they're confused
about everything and then you start
pushing on all sorts of anti-American
stuff and you have people you have
queers for Palestine literally chanting
to destroy the one country where they
could live while they're chanting
alongside the people who would gladly
behead them but if you've already
chopped your genitals off I guess your
head maybe isn't that important so we
have an algorithmic problem we have the
bot problem also right like it's it is a
huge problem and I'm telling you I saw
someone sent me from one of like these
Neo-Nazi telegram groups where they have
hundreds of thousands of people in them
and what they did was they posted Ben
tweet in the in there and then they said
go ahead and ratio it so that thousands
of people then come into Ben's mentions
and write all sorts of awful things and
it makes it seem like oh no one agrees
with Ben because they're manipulating
the system so we have those problems we
have the problem that our political
leaders aren't that great and all of
those things like it it is a wild mess
right now and on top of the fact that
there are there is a massive uh War
happening in the Middle East we've still
got the Russia Ukraine thing China's
making a move clearly on California like
there is a lot of stuff right now but I
nothing better to do to save the world
do you Amy Says are you making any
special dish or dessert for the boys to
enjoy for their first non non bottled
Thanksgiving meal yes they are mostly on
solid food foods thank you for changing
the topic really appreciate it um they
are mostly on solid foods these days
although still doing some bottles uh you
know when we had both of their first
birthdays uh my sister-in-law kin she
made the most extraordinary we showed it
in the locals Community these incredible
cakes with no sugar like literally using
like pea dye to color P pea pea dye like
peas dye to like color the cake and it
was made out of like yogurt and cottage
cheese or whatever to get let them Mash
their cakes so these kids are eating
organic and super healthy and it's
reflective definitely in their health
and their size they're both huge and
happy um what will be the special thing
I don't know can we maybe we'll try some
apple pie with them like we've they've
like basically had no sugar but maybe
like little apple pie might be good or
I'll give them some of my smoked turkey
we shall see
Ben says what movies are you enjoying
these days anything recent man you know
I still haven't seen Oppenheimer I know
everyone's telling me I got to see it it
comes out on Apple TV I think next week
so we'll probably do that with the
family during Thanksgiving um I have not
seen anything new or interesting I told
you guys the the show that I'm watching
right now but it's on HBO and they only
release it every Sunday it's old school
they don't let you binge watch it that
way is um the Gilded Age which is really
interesting it's about the the
aristocrats of New York City on the
Upper East Side in in around the 1880s
and it was written by Julian fellows who
wrote Downtown Abbey and I really love
Downtown Abbey just seeing that uh
Downtown Abbey which of course took
place in you know 1920s 30s maybe in not
quite into the 40s 20s and 30s uh in
England what life was like there for the
rich people upstairs and the servants
downstairs uh and then you see a version
of that in America in what we call the
guilded age uh all right we're getting
some questions live on the Fly today to
mix it up Florida man Chuck says Jordan
Peterson ask asks the question all the
time but what in your opinion would need
to happen for people on the left to
finally come to their senses and throw
their hands up with this whole charade
does Hamas need to attack someone in the
alphabet Mafia in America or does
someone have to die from gender
reassignment surgery or become
completely mutilated from it all uh to
all be too
far this is the this is the maybe the
most important question right now
because after uh the the October 7th
attacks we saw this wakeup of a lot of
people on the left now it tended to be
uh a lot of Jewish people lefties
Democrat lefties but then a lot of other
people just like the moderate Democrat
types were like whoa whoa whoa what's
going on here it's our guys who are now
chanting for more genocide it's our guys
who are excusing these like unspeakable
uh acts and all of that stuff they start
waking up and that's also what's what's
a shame about this Ben Candice thing and
partly why I almost didn't want to cover
it today because that's a thing that's
happening on Twitter now it's it's
bursting forth into the mainstream and
and I'm sure it'll be all over YouTube
and Rumble and everywhere else today but
I kind of was like maybe if I just
ignore it a bit or give it a pause for a
couple days it won't just add more to it
because when you see the ugliness that's
happening on the right right now and
that's what I'm addressing here um and
some of that I do put at the foot of
Candace I put some of it at the foot of
Tucker and by the way and again Tucker
who I like and wrote a blurb for the
back of my book and all that stuff it's
like no no one is above criticism right
I'm not above criticism either um but
why it's so disappointing with what's
happening on the right right now is
there's there's a huge swath of people a
group of people that I always say are
the one group of people who could move
who could actually vote a different way
and we know that because the amount of
liberals who have moved down to Florida
or to Texas who now vote solidly red
well if they start seeing Chaos on the
right and what the hell's going on with
these people and that's a whole bunch of
craziness over there I thought Dave said
they were kind of decent then they are
just going to be pushed back to the
Democrats so it's it's a huge problem I
don't know what it will take like do I
you're right though you're right would
it take a Hamas style bus bombing or
suicide bombing or another unspeakable
thing to happen here to wake some people
up would it take well look the an we
know the answer is kind of no the
movement itself doesn't stop you know
the movement might have taken pause when
a trans person with a uh with a grudge
shot up that Christian school but I
didn't see the trans movement stop and
now the trans movement is largely
because intersectionality is a movement
forged in Hell uh now they're just
continuing so I don't know I don't know
Susan says why can't people just talk
face to face stop with the public social
media fights it puts these people at the
same level as the controlling media and
government clowns it's gotten
increasingly difficult you know you guys
know like especially for those of you
that have been with me since the
beginning some of those clips we showed
you earlier from from 16 and 17 like it
was much easier for me years ago to sit
down with people who who thought
differently than me and I
suppose it was because I was on the left
and I was waking up to what was
happening on the right so I was willing
to have that conversation but I have
always found conservatives and religious
people generally far more willing to
engage in open conversation and right
now we're seeing that devolve uh because
emotions are high
and and again I think emotions should be
high I think it was a really
um I will not bmer Tucker's intent with
the question but I think if he would
have perhaps thought about it a little
bit more he would have understood why
emotions are so high why perhaps a
specific group of people in this case
might be a bit emotionally sensitive
about this thing again I haven't seen
Ben's emotions be disregulated actually
one of the most beautiful maybe the most
beautiful thing that I've seen since
this all has happened is that when I was
at the the show at at the O2 in London
with Jordan and there were about
probably 20,000 people there Ben was the
surprise guest and when they when Jordan
introduced Ben the Applause were insane
like absolutely insane but what you
could tell were the Applause were not
just because it was Ben it was because
of what Ben represented and it was
important for those people in that
audience in London where they have had
some of the most outrageous protest TS
and calls for genocide and the and the
attacks on their monuments and all of
those things you could feel that Ben was
in some ways an avatar for something
else and it wasn't an avatar for oh
applaud the Jew it was an avatar for oh
applaud the guy that's fighting
alongside of us that wants to live in a
western Society the way we want to live
in a western society which again is why
I would say the fight for Israel is the
exact same fight that ultimately will be
the fight for America because it's not
going to stop with Israel and it's the
same fight
that will be the fight to save Britain
and France Etc uh Richard says do you
think the reason that conservatives
particularly Republicans fail so often
is that the minute they enjoy any
success slum they turn on each other
well I suppose we're seeing a version of
that right now I don't know that there's
been a lot of wins for conservatives or
Republicans lately I mean just look at
the elections a couple weeks ago uh but
I think the the the greater point on
that is that the left large Lely has
become a cult likee movement you believe
in everything we believe when we believe
it and if you do not get on board and if
you don't um ascribe to our oppressor
oppressor oppress narrative and all of
those things if you don't do it the
second we want you are evil and that
that is a cult like Nar you either with
us or against us right and people on the
right conservatives Republicans tend to
be more agree to disagree and that's not
the way it's framed right through
culture right culture would tell you
that religious people are the most
dogmatic and everything else but again I
have consistently found usually
Evangelical Christians to be quite
honest uh the the most open and decent
but religious people by and large when
we were in Israel in Jerusalem we had a
Shabbat dinner for my entire team with a
uh Ultra Orthodox very very religious
family in Jerusalem they knew who I am
they're fans of the show they know about
me and who I'm married to and all of
those things and they welome welcome
their home to us and I would say that's
the same exact thing that I've seen out
of the Christian Community the the left
has figured out a way to keep everyone
so hysterical all the time that they are
they are bound by something that is not
good but it does keep them tight and the
right is bound more by individual rights
more by freedom and the glue of that
should be much tighter but the glue of
that because there's a respect for who
you are and how you behave and
understanding that oh you don't want to
create a government that will tell EXA
exactly everybody exactly how to live
that glue is is more susceptible to to
being melted and not working they know
that man Joe says Dave my husband and I
are coming to Florida to march to
explore the keys before we fly back home
to Boise we relocated here three years
ago from outside of Seattle and love it
congratulations on getting out of
Seattle we have for nights plan to stay
in Miami to enjoy the beach any
suggestions on a location or specific
Hotel Hotel oh man you know I'm I'm a
homebody now when it like I have barely
got out in the last year specific Hotel
um you know the W Hotel in I think it's
in South Beach has a really awesome uh
rooftop was it the W it's the W over
there has a pretty awesome Rooftop Bar
and uh uh what else what else is good
you you guys are young you're hanging
out The Standard Hotel it's a little
younger kind of funky what else we got
what about give me a restaurant
something where do people go
go go yeah go to Cocoa walk in in
Coconut Grove is just like a great clean
City atmosphere a lot of great little
restaurants and all that stuff um I wish
I knew more I basically don't go
anywhere anymore um but I used to go out
I was cool uh Jill says can you
recommend an affordable tequila under 50
bucks well first off we are working on
my tequila right now it is it is basting
in the casket stay tuned on that uh
affordable under 50 bucks right so the
one that I'm always promoting to you
guys is is classa I just love it and I
know it's expensive it's like 150 bucks
but I just think it's great and it's
it's just very accessible in terms of
flavor palette for people that don't
necessarily love tequila uh tequila oo
uh is under 50 bucks it's probably
around you probably get the reposado for
like 40 bucks it's clean it's pure there
are no additives it's it's really really
Pleasant and drinkable and you can sip
it let me know what you think toway says
what are your thoughts on the people who
attended dinner with XI jingping like
Tim Cook and Larry think and Stanley
deal just business as usual PR is this a
sign of them continuing to move closer
to the Communist regime's ways and what
takeaways uh should Americans have so I
didn't see that specifically but I'll
I'll take your word for it I think there
is a big problem happening right now in
California and it's being exported
probably throughout the entire country
not through just through some of these
companies but also with Gavin what Gavin
Newsome just showed us Gavin Newsome
showed us that you can as a Democrat do
the right thing when it comes to these
cities you can clean up you can make
sure your streets are safe for people
you don't have to have Fentanyl and
everything else everywhere again many
people have been complaining about the
fenel thing how many stories have I done
about San Francisco Tucker right
like but Gavin I think was doing a
little test can we put the Chinese flags
up all over San Francisco have a mass uh
rally for communist leaders and
communist leaders who consolidate power
and treat their people very poorly maybe
I can kind of bring them here and we can
start importing some of those ideas
right I think we thought when when we
sort of defrosted relations with China
over the last couple decades I think we
thought that China would Veer more
towards freedom but it seems to me we
are realizing we are veering more
towards towards authoritarianism and
that's probably because we have a bunch
of bad leaders and a culture that
doesn't know how to defend itself okay a
couple more on the Fly Tonka says why
are the Republicans doing such an awful
job sorry such an awful job capitalizing
on the Looney left's ridiculous policies
including their March towards socialism
it seems like the opportunity of a
lifetime to make Republicans the
majority party but aren't we they
blowing it is it Trump populism
something else look I am still hopeful
for the presidential election as I have
said and I know no you know no one else
in conventional wisdom is saying it I
don't know why Kim Reynolds a super
popular governor of Iowa decided to
throw in with a guy that we're supposed
to believe is 50 points down who just
went to all 99 counties and everything
else you Iowa I think Iowa is going to
surprise people I really do uh maybe I
am just a dreamer but whatever happens
at the end of this thing I did what I
thought was right the entire time that
that's one thing oh but the reason I
mentioned that is
because there was such an opportunity
for Republicans imagine if Trump had
said you know what I'm going to be uh
I'm going to sit this one out but I but
to santis is the future obviously look
what he's done in Florida it's why I
live in Florida it's why my
grandchildren and all my kids live in
Florida look what he did on covid look
how he's gotten ESG out of schools that
he fought Disney he's younger he's ready
to roll let's do this I will defend him
I will run rallies I will fight the
media on his behalf we could have the
most United Republican party probably
probably in the history of America I
would say even bigger than Ronald re
Reagan's re-election when he won I think
49 states like most people would be
getting it right now DeSantis would be
able to bring in some new people the
Maga base would happy like that would be
it now you could be watching this going
day but what about the reverse of that
how about the santis should have just
stepped out or he should have endorsed
Trump the problem is that a certain set
of people just hate Trump no matter what
we know that Trump already has some sort
of uh ceiling on the amount of people
who are going to vote for him right like
where are the new Trump voters it's just
a simple thing and again if Trump thinks
that the election was stolen then then
why do the polls matter right now
meaning the national polls when he's
pimping out the idea that he's up in
five of the six swing States it's like
well okay that's that's nice to hear I'm
glad to hear that truly but why does it
matter if they stole if they stole it
from you like you have to address that
you just have to address that so it is a
damn shame what's happening with the
Republican party I would say actually
your question is directly related to why
the Candice then Tucker situation is
frustrating and why I promise you that I
will continue to do my best to to put
these pieces together and not have
everybody at everybody's throats but I
suppose that's going to be the hardest
position to have huh that's funny jansy
says have you been surprised at John
fed's support for Israel it's really
bizarre look I have been very critical
of Federman the guy has trouble
stringing the sentences together we get
all that I think that the idea that
you're going to wear
sweatshirts and and the lack of
professionals and all that but he's been
bizarrely good on Israel the fact that
there is a Democrat that is like
fighting and doing the right thing is
good who knows that everything is
so it's just we're in a millu of lunacy
at the moment and you got to pick when
you find the bright spots like let's
find that bright spot whoever it's with
oh my God that democrat's not a lunatic
let me see if I can build some bridges
there that Republican hasn't completely
gone off into the deep end on this thing
let's see if we can bring those things
there and again guys that's what America
used to be right that's what America
used to be good liberals and good
conservatives used to sit down all the
time they would do TV shows together
they would break bread together
sometimes they would even marry each
other the thing that we're dealing with
now is much more dangerous and just
remember it's largely artificial it's
largely algorithm based it's largely
bot-based it's largely based in a in a
grifting class of pundits that want you
to keep hating everybody and again I
suppose the challenge for me the
challenge for you and the challenge for
everybody loves America is not to fall
for it this has been a very bizarre show
for me I hope I hope that I didn't open
the gates of hell on me uh with the with
the Bots and the Monsters but I probably
did and you know what either way I've
got kids in a decent life and I like the
people I work with and what are we
having for lunch today oh we're having
Israeli food for lunch which that'll
really now freak him out thanks for
watching guys postgame show in just a
sec Ruben report. locals.com oh and by
the way my uh you know we've been laying
out all these Arc interviews we did so
many of them it just took a little time
uh my full interview with yuran Brook
from the iron ran ins is up right now uh
and another reminder that we have
started a new Twitter account just for
show clips to make that stuff very
easily sharable it's at Ruben report
show we'll see you guys on the other
side of postgame and then at 1:00 on
people of the internet oh and we've got
a close c a cold close for you how about
wise Ronald Reagan go all of it began
the first time some of you who know
better and are old enough to know better
let young people think think that they
had the right to choose the laws they
would obey as long as they were doing it
in the name of social
[Music]
protest